All right, so today I'm going to be talking about this initiative that I led to reduce
postman's start-up time on low-end devices.
This involved work across Electrom Web and also organizational execution.
My role was a staff engineer.
I was part of the front-end platform team and the stack was an electron application and
a very, very large single-punch application powering the WebView part of Electrom.
This was a multi-tenant, sorry, multi-team performance initiative across many months with
multiple stakeholders and a lot of people in their business.
I'm going to be showing how I helped defining this problem, choosing the right metric, also
the key technical decisions I had to make in this case and how I influence other engineers
and the business to execute just not to improve performance but also introduce a culture of
performance.
So it was not just like a one-off exercise and then everybody would get back to their
jobs and then just forget about performance after that.
So let's get started.
I'm going to go deeper into a lot of the technical aspects of this problem.
For example, when I'm going to be talking about the optimizations in Electron I'm going
to go deeply technical on those.
How this all started?
So the problem became real when the CEO of Postman went to Amazon and then bought a laptop,
really, really cheap Intel setup on laptop and then he tried running Postman on it and
he brought it to the office and that was very, very painful to watch.
It was really, really slow and you could take about 30 to 50 seconds to even just load and
it would just crash.
You know, the frequently crashing, there would be high spikes of CPU and it basically was
unusable.
The app would not work and this was a wake-up call, it was terrible to watch but the reason
this mattered and it was not just because we wanted to prove that Postman had a performance
problem is this was actually affecting our users.
Why this was a big problem was because the product was basically unusable for a large
segment of the users that own lower end devices.
It created not just a reputational risk but also a churn, you know, if people, if they
pay up is broken, people are just going to churn and they'll come back and the product
basically didn't work.
And also when the reputation of Postman was notorious, people were calling Postman, you
know, he's blocked it, he doesn't work, he's too slow, it's a really, really slow app.
So this was affecting the product and it was affecting the business and we, this was the
wake-up call for us to figure out how to improve the performance.
That's where I came in.
So we had this performance, a performance team before and I came in and we knew the
problem was a big significant but this is when I took ownership to look at this problem
and try to come up with a solution from the engineering perspective as part of the platform
team.
So I took this as a task to lead to a solution coming up with the solution to this problem.
First of all, what I had to do was define the correct metric.
So how are you going to measure the performance of the application?
So first of all, we already, as I mentioned, we had a performance team before and people
before me, they've been doing some things like introducing like high-house calls and
trying to check core way vitals.
But all of these metrics were segmented across multiple areas of the application.
There was no single view of performance of the entire application.
So those metrics were mainly on the renderer process, so the electron has main and renderer.
And the renderer process, well, you can measure the performance and have a lot of metrics,
but there was no overview how long to take from when you open the app until you can do
something.
And that's where I came up with this metric.
I call that time to usability.
The reason or the way that I got inspired by this was a few things.
So from, I don't know if you're familiar with, like, I think this is a time in game
and I'm not a gamer, but it's called time to fun.
So the metric that games track is when they open the game and how long does it take for
people to have fun.
So I thought, well, our app is not game, but how long does it take for people to launch
their app and actually do something meaningful?
And this is having inspired by VS Code and a lot of other applications where they also
measure this, for example, VS Code, they measure when the application launches and then the
cursor is ticking.
And from the Slack as well, it's an electron app when you open Slack and then they measure
how long it takes for the sending message box to appear.
So I was inspired and I came up with this time to usability.
It's a custom metric.
I came up with it.
It didn't record outside of a person.
But it is a metric where we are measuring how long does it take for the time that you
click the button on the launchpad until you are ready to perform a task, which is, in
this case, postman send requests.
So I call this the critical task.
So in launch, the JavaScript is ready, the data is loaded, and then we are ready to send
a request.
It was very important to come up with an off-start metric because I didn't want to have optimizations
everywhere.
I wanted to focus on just one thing.
And the most impactful thing was, I looked at how many, what was the things that users
were doing when they launched the application?
And of course, the first thing they do is sending a request.
So it was a data-driven decision and we wanted to optimize for that initial experience.
Like you open the app.
You are ready to send a request.
There you go.
The target was 10 seconds.
So we wanted to ensure the application, and this is on low-end devices, by the way the
target on high-end devices was way lower, 10 seconds is still quite low.
But again, we are focusing on low-end devices and choosing these 10 seconds, I looked at
some research and I think I read a really, it's not probably old paper where the multiples
of 10 were in one minute and sorry, in one second, in 10 seconds and one minute.
I think 10 seconds is like the amount of time for an application, I mean three conferences
different but for an application to make sure that you don't lose track.
Like if I open the app after 10 seconds, I'll be like, the app is not working and they just
forget about it.
So we had the target.
We chosen the target.
We chosen what we're going to be measuring.
The next time was, what instrumentation, so I looked at the instrumentation methods and
of course DTU, the time to use ability, my trick that I came up with, it was a bit difficult
to measure with the current tools, you know, like we don't have that in my house.
And also there was a challenge on how we're going to measure the whole process, from the
main process to actually when the rendering happens.
So the instrumentation strategy was using their browser native APIs, in this case, this performance
mark, performance measure, to segment the different stages of the launch of that critical
path that I defined and looking at how long each segment of these process takes.
So using performance on mark, we can say, you know, the platform initialise here, then
we put another marker when that process finishes and the next one continues.
And then you can just aggregate all those markers and then I'll give you the total
launch time at the end, but you can also see the segments on how long each individual parts
were taken.
So we could have, well, how long the main process takes, how long the JavaScript parts
in the learning compilation, how long the data fetching and how long the rendering of
the workspace it was taken.
So this was locally, of course, but also we wanted to focus on real user metrics.
So there was not a lot of synthetic monitoring at that point, but I decided to focus on user
monitoring because we wanted to see the impact on users, we didn't want just to make nice
key dashboards and things that worked internally, but we wanted to see immediate impact on the
user.
So we sent this to the RAM, which is Postman's internal analytics.
And then we segmented all this by device, CPU class region.
So Postman has all of these different types of users.
So I collected those metrics, and that gave us a really nice segmentation.
So it was not just like a path, like a number, it was just a segmentation.
So we can see if we were making progress or not.
So the big umbrella question, so why is the app so slow?
So after having this representation, and I look at the data and static collecting data
from the users, the million dollar question was, hey, what's the app so slow and the results
were very interesting.
So 22% of the app was taken by the main process, and 38% by JavaScript and a lot of parsing
and compiling, and the rest was taken by the API calls and rendering.
And you can see this graph.
I managed to get for all the spans of different segments that we had.
And it was not surprising, but it was nice to see what the application was so slow.
So a huge chunk of the application start time was going in this blue section.
Nothing was happening.
It was a loading spinner during that 38% before anything even rendered on the screen.
So to reduce the start time, we wanted to focus on all of these areas.
The outcome of this was, I don't give you the actual segmentation on how to solve the
problem.
And I created this document, so I compiled all of these different results and graphs
and dashboards, and I put them into a document to explain to the business and all the stakeholders
and all of the engineers in the department.
So what the problem was, and with the real user metrics.
So I sent this to everybody, I got a lot of comments, people were questioning the measurements,
people were questioning why we have such a big bundle.
And I had to answer a lot of questions in here, but then at least I had arguments based on
data how to present this to people and how to try to gain that convincing people and
gain that support from them to go and do something about it.
Because at least now we have something to start with.
So the focus was, what do we focus on, like, what do we do?
As I mentioned, we wanted to focus on the highest return of investment areas, and our
premature optimization, optimizing things that are not going to produce a lot of value.
So the prioritization, I made this decision where I would just focus 100% on the data
section, which is the JavaScript execution, compilation, and download and parsing.
Because it was the main area, and it was not doing anything, that was just pure overhead,
and I wanted to focus on that.
But of course, this initiative was not just one section, I wanted to get the entire business
together.
And even though we were going to focus on the main bundle optimization and parsing and compiling,
there were also other tracks, I call them tracks, in terms of what other people would
be doing, improving performance in other areas, like networking, data fetching, and also the
main process in Electron.
So trying to get the buy-in from the organization was interesting.
I went to every single head of the department, after sending the document, there were a lot
of questions, but still had they needed a lot of convincing still.
And I went to ask for resources, and this is always an interesting discussion because they
wanted to ask how long it's going to take, how many people.
And we have an essay in Postman and the team down here, which is nevertheless we ship,
meaning we're not going to stop the business, we're still shipping features, and we're not
going to stop, and we're just going to fix it.
So I managed to secure buy-in from the business and the stakeholders, and I managed to get
at least committed to engineers per team to focus on performance, and make sure that that
was their focus.
That performance is important for everybody, and it's a business problem, it's not just
a technical problem, and it's not just an issue for their platform team or just a performance
team or whatever.
So I created this plan, presented it, and I started executing.
Before I talk about the main part that I focus on, there are other tracks like the improvements
to the network.
I'm just going to be briefing this one, but it was mainly that there were a lot of network
requests, a lot of feature flags, a lot of data that ride too late for the initial render.
So solution, a lot of low honey fruit, introduce some prefetching, collecting a lot of data,
and talking to the back end, so sometimes talking at the back end, the front end folks
and the back end folks don't talk to each other, and then the front end folks, they need to
talk a little bit more, because there are some times where the issues actually the data.
The front end might be slow, they might be some problems, but if an API is taking a lot
of time, or you are calling, in this case, we're calling hundreds of APIs.
So there was an aggregation coordination with the back end team to ensure that APIs were
faster, some aggregated endpoints for the critical data were created.
There was a brief mention of GraphQL at that point, and I think I shot it very quickly.
I think for Postman as an application, that was one of those premature optimizations
that I wanted to stop, because maybe, yeah, that would help with aggregation, et cetera,
but to be honest, we could get a lot more output just by combining a few APIs and cleaning
up the log of having a free drive and introducing a brand new tool in structure for the data
fetching, which probably wasn't that needed that long.
So we fixed the feature flags and all of this prefetching and performance of .NET, and the
inside was, you know, this is not just focusing on the front end, this is interesting, this
is what I do, but also there is a lot of all this stuff that can be done off from the back
end for improving performance.
Right, so in this slide, I'm going to spend a lot of time, because this is the main thing
I did, this was my main involvement, my main focus challenge was the JavaScript person
and compilation.
So I took the team, the platform team, a few engineers, and this was my responsibility,
and this was my strong bet, just a little bit of context first.
So while this was a big problem, the bundle for Postman was 14 megabytes of JavaScript
mini files, and there is a reason for this, it'd be like, why are you doing 14 megabytes
for Postman?
It's a nearly code editor, we have really heavy dependencies, but it was also because
the application was originally an electron application, and all the files were bundled
with the electron, but after a while, Postman decided to go on updates over the air, meaning
that you could potentially update the application without having to download the entire bundle,
the entire executable binary, but the problem is that it was built as a single file, it
was not built as a web app, it was built to set, and then you take it up with a bunch
of files where you don't care about how much JavaScript you put in there, because it's
in the main process.
The application was also very old, Postman was 10 years old at this point, and it's been
iterations, migration, things that were never finished.
So the one thing is very, very hard to make sense of what the code was in there.
JavaScript cost is not just network, it's also parsing and compiling.
So parsing and compiling JavaScript, people don't realize how much the compilation step
takes when you have a large bundle, so of course downloading from the network takes
a long time, but once JavaScript arrives, you have a big cost of parsing and compiling.
So I created this graph tractor on the standard, I went to webpack stats, and then tried to
run the bundle on theizer, and I created this visualization and it crashed my laptop
a few times, just to show you how bad the problem was.
This I call the supernova modern graph, this is a real modular graph, with I don't know
how many thousands of noise, and it was bad, like 700 circle dependencies.
It was a terrible problem, and that's the context on why we had so much hours correct.
Now, what do we do in this case?
I have two approaches, and I'm gonna go deeper into the two proposals that I put forward
and why it was not chosen, and a little bit of back history.
So like manager postman, I was meant to join to improve the modularization and re-architecture
of the application.
So I was familiar with the things I wanted to do to improve this, so the application
was solved, and I was struggling basically.
So I wanted to do the modularization and fix the root cause, and I was one approach, and
just to be honest, to clarify, I was not advocating for a full rewrite.
So people would come and say, "Hey, this is really bad, let's go and rewrite it from scratch."
That's not the approach I was suggesting with the modularization.
I came up with a lot of different, no migration, but improvements, avenues for modularization
with strangling parts and incremental, removable, and keep changing the different parts and
modularizing the parts with how to rewrite and make a binary rewrite.
So it was not like a massive migrational rewrite, it was a modular approach.
And I had a lot of evidence and I've been working on that for a while.
The other option was, well, let's figure out why this is so bad, instead of doing the
old modularization initiative and apply some performance techniques and see how far we can
get.
Unfortunately, I went to convince everybody about the modularization.
I convinced my colleagues to go to the heads of the department and explain why it wasn't
just good for performance.
It was also good for the long-term health and architecture of the application to have
a modular, basically to clean up, it was just a mess.
But at the end, after convincing everybody, and I thought I convinced the head of engineering
as well, but I think he changed his mind and he said he didn't want us to go that way.
I guess to reduce risk, I didn't agree with the assessment.
I thought the solution of modularization was probably better, but of course the risk and
at that point there was an unknown.
He was a big bet and the head of engineering had the last say and he said no, let's just
try to patch the architecture and figure out how to fix it without having to implement
this massive modularization plan.
So the solution chosen, I was like, okay, fine, let's do, let's see what we can do.
It's a business decision, the technical decision, I presented all my arguments, but see what
we can do.
So the first thing I did was, well, let's try and patch this.
Let's go through why this module graph and try to understand this module graph and how
to untangle it.
So I came across a tool called status code, which is much better than the weight loss
stats.
And today, there's a better one called ours doctor, which is based on our webpack.
So this tool, when I found this tool was eye opening, it was a turning point because before
nobody understood what was going on, this crashing my computer, I couldn't even understand
where all the circular dependencies and why the bundle was a huge.
But with this tool that I found, I analyzed the bundle and I could find the different
modules, graphs, import chains, and why the application was being injected, because even
after lazy loading and co-splitting, they were still getting inside because of the
circular dependencies.
So I gave the team today's tool, I gave them the tools to find out what they could do and
start splitting lazy loading dependency, proving aggressive.
This is what they took so long, one of the parts of the project that took a long time
because the team had to go, look at their code, look at the dependencies, start cutting
things, remove their code, replace the load, code splits, etc.
So it took a few months and we managed to get the bundle from 14 megabytes to 2.7 megabytes
or JavaScript, which was a huge, I didn't even think that we could get, it was a huge
reduction from thing to tool, and then before we go into that, and then everybody was happy
and now this comes in the here's journey story, when you are, yeah everything is great, performance
is solved, and actually it was not bad, something unexpected happened, after this work, everybody
putting so much effort into this, the bundled reductions didn't immediately produce the
expected gains.
So I was expecting that you remove and reduce the JavaScript bundle, and then the time to
use ability metric in real-time, real user metrics would just drop at the same time, at
the same pace as the bundle, because my theory was, there is a lot of work that is happening
in there, and if you reduce the amount of work of parsing, compiling, downloading, then
it naturally this will go down, but the observance, it was improving, but not as fast.
We improved by like 10 and a second, we were like at 27, 26 seconds, and everybody started
questioning everything, questioning me, because I asked the one who proposed this, and the
one that was very convinced that improving the bundle would improve the performance,
so I questioned myself, everybody started questioning me, questioned the metrics, are
the metrics correct, are we making a measurement errors, are we not getting the data, what's
going on with the metrics.
They also, I was trying to verify my assumptions, is JavaScript, the bottleneck, am I missing
something?
I was like, I could not look at the metrics, I was like, am I missing something?
So I also started getting pushed back from the business, I was in the big trouble, because
the heads of the department were like, hey, you know, we're investing in this, we spend
a lot of time.
Why is the performance now coming down?
My boss asking questions, everybody asks questions, everybody looking at me.
So how do I get out of this?
I take a step back, I had a conviction that this was the right approach, but there must
be something else that is happening.
So back to analysis, we just started using some contrasting on the main process and trying
to figure out why the JavaScript bundle was still taking, that section was taking so
long, and interesting, we found one debug, and I am happy to go in details on what the
bug, this is a very, very interesting bug, but in summary was there was a hidden main
thread, like a block in an electron.
So it's something that actually I did, at the beginning of the initiative, I lazy loaded
the initialization of the JavaScript, so I created like a bootstrap and then just lazy
loaded the rest of the application, the big bundle.
And that caused the document on load event to come sooner, and then the main process
was listening to this, to do also some lazy loading, which meant that the main process
was blocking the render when the JavaScript was parsing that compiling, meaning it was
sequential, it was a race condition between these two, so we get sometimes a variable results,
and also it was just blocking completely the main process, and the matrix was telling us
that the render was taking long, but it was an outcome from the main process.
So the main lesson I learned here was don't block the main process of electron, because
that is the sacred process, you should not block it, and I found this bug delayed our
execution for a long time.
So after we fixed this bug, the news was the time to usability, the launch performance
had immediate sharp drop, I remember looking at the metrics, and the metrics were like coming
down like crazy, I was like, wow, it was like your present button, performance went down
like 10 seconds lower, like in within like a week, and then you keep dropping.
So it was difficult, but I managed to find that, I'm going to focus on a couple of advanced
buttons, I think they'll be very useful if I discuss them, because the bundle was interesting,
but there was still some of the things that we could do, and after looking at the current
tracing we realized, okay, the main process probably we can improve other things, because
you'll be thinking, oh, the main process, these are all the electron stuff, we are not
going to be fixing electron performance, these are overhead, but actually that was not true,
there was a lot of stuff still in the main process that we could do, and one of those
was my bundling the main process, so I think we used RSPAC at that point to bundle the
main process that gave us a couple of seconds of improvement at P90, then there was a persistent
database called JSON Electron Storage, which was very, very slow, removing that, and then
finally, RSSI requires, because in the main process we also have a lot of dependencies
and a lot of code that was not needed, but then after removing the code that was not needed,
there was still a lot of code that was required, the startup, so there was one interesting
optimization technique that we started looking with the main process, the team had a couple
of good engineers from C++ backgrounds, and they were really good at looking at the electron
process, and they proposed this, V8 snapshot, which was basically compiling these dependencies,
converting them into native code, so that required impact would be removed.
I tested this, but I personally pushed back a lot on this approach, because first of all
the results, they presented were interesting, but they were not that much compared to the
risk, so for example, my concern is very complex, it requires C++ engineers maintaining
these mappings for every dependency, and not just the maintenance, what happens when you
update the dependency, so there was some maintenance, a lot of complexity, and the gains were really
small compared to the risk, so eventually I just suggested against this, and I advanced
against using this alternative, but there were other alternatives, and all the things
that were actually implemented that were advanced, this case were the renderer, so after reducing
the bundle, we're thinking, okay, what else, can we reduce the bundle even more, but there
were things like using a better compression, and then the service worker, service worker
catching all the assets on an update, so we can have the assets downloaded ahead of time,
so when you launch the application, those assets are not going to be downloaded from
the network, they will come from the service worker, and we're not paying that latency,
but as I mentioned earlier, the parsing and compiling of JavaScript is also very expensive,
so there was one last thing that we could do, and this was an advance of the message with
the service worker, which was called the bytecode caching by a service worker install, so bytecode
caching, JavaScript is a just-in-time compile language, and every time that you try to use
one of these files to create, I think it will compile the file just in time, so this optimization
consisted on pre-compiling that file, and then just put it into the caching, and V8 does
this for you, but this optimization in particular is in a full bytecode caching, meaning that
the entirety of the file is pre-compiled ahead of time, not just incrementally, there is
an article that shows how that works automatically, but this was like a very aggressive caching
on the JavaScript install.
So the outcome, this was material, the byte did work, never became done, we managed to
get the app from 30 seats, P90 to 12.5 seconds, or on high-end devices, this was even, you
know, the improvements were also noticed, you know, from one to two seconds, on really
high-end Macs, but at 12.5 seconds, at that point, they would like to be started to, we
started to see diminishing returns, so we never got to the ten-second goal, I don't
think it was a failure that we didn't get to the ten seconds, but it was mostly, we
started all optimizing, and there were all the things that had to be fixed before we
can get to the ten seconds, which turned out to be a lot of the architectural problems
that I mentioned at the beginning, that they needed to be solved, and there will be a more
drastic approach that will be needed for us to go beyond ten seconds, not just ten seconds,
but beyond for really, really old devices, they became usable from a lot of people, you
know, like a lot of people who couldn't use the app before now can use the app, user experience
was improved, not just for the lowest devices, but everyone, and of course it led to better,
you know, reduced frustration from users and churn.
So my learning was, you know, I want to optimize for value, I could have assessed over this
metric and get ten seconds, but we achieved the user value, which was that the users were
able to use the app now, and they just go through ten seconds.
On the organizational side, before I came to this project, there was just an isolated
team working on performance by themselves, and they could not make a lot of progress,
it was a lack prioritization, lack of ownership, there was an only show of regression, basically
performance was no one's problem, but then when I came into this project, I just established
a company-wide initiative, and they find a metric, they know a star, so everybody knows
what needs to happen and how we're measuring it, and then after that, I also introduced
PR checks to block regression because we didn't want this to become one single-time exercise,
and then the performance would just take a noise-life after the performance initiative
was completed, so a new team for synthetic monitoring and ensuring that the releases
are blocked to the performance tests are not complete, they're not passing.
The outcome, I was proud of this because everybody's performance became everybody's
responsibility, I was known as the performance guy, that that would be telling people about
performance performance, then the product improved, and we make sure that we didn't
regret it, so performance accelerated when you still become an niche problem, it was
a company problem and more like a part of engineering execution, so I'm proud that
I made this part of the engineering organization and DNA, rather than just a single project.
My experience can help here with the code exam, I was involved in the work on electron
performance, so I believe my skills and experience with this is very important as they call
exam gets bigger, and we can make it super up, managing large-scale, large-scale applications,
this is not just for electrons, but performance across large-class conferences, our script,
applications and performance optimization techniques, and the electron, I'm sorry,
postman, as codecs is a developer tool and developers are very picky, so improving their
performance and gaining the developer love is something that I've been doing for a while.
Most importantly, this required a relentless execution and it required cross-functional
collaboration, organizational enlightenment, a relentless execution from my part, so I'm
really proud of this project.